[Music]
[Applause]
Anthony Slater covers the Warriors and
the NBA for the athletic he was there
last night set the scene there Anthony
it was all fun and games everybody okay
with uh on the same page with the
Warriors
sure you know I mean it's like the
celebratory night where they celebrate
last season yeah I would say there's
still some awkwardness uh you know among
Draymond Green and his teammates uh and
even you know in the press conference
there remains a little bit of iciness I
think on Jordan poolside but
you know the veterans have defended
Jordan Poole so forcefully uh and then
you know they keep winning and and and
and you can win within that I think
draymond's had some comments TNT has a
documentary on him and it's almost like
he embraced this it's not like he is
remorseful whatsoever
is that your read on Draymond through
all of this
I mean he's he at least his initial
press conference accepted responsibility
that he was at at fault there were a
couple times within the press conference
you could tell he was trying to hint at
like well if you knew the full context
but we shouldn't even go down that road
um so there's a there's a level of
defiance with him and in his second
press conference was not quite as
contrived as his first one and like you
said you know not only did he do the
documentary last night but he's had
these like three documentary like uh you
know photographers or videographers that
were around all Camp which is always an
interesting thing to happen
um
it's I know it's been put by a few
people like this feels like the uh end
days of a marriage where the kids aren't
quite yet off to college but you're
you're sticking together because the
greater goal and the greater goal is
this is still the title favorite
probably and a chance to win five but
with every you know the money situation
and and the the transitioning of eras
within this franchise that it feels like
has created a kind of odd umbrella over
everything yet I mean they look as good
as ever
did those camera guys working on the
documentary catch any of the fight with
Jordan pool and Draymond Green were they
at the practice
I don't believe so because we would have
saw HD footage if so right I mean I
haven't well they might be holding it
though Anthony if if they've got it and
and Draymond seems to almost Embrace Hey
man people know who I am and social
media and New Media and all of that uh
you know it's not hey it's just one
thing who cares yeah well I I didn't
actually I heard it was like a 25 minute
pregame Docker I actually I've seen some
of the clips of him talking I haven't
seen the whole thing they show I heard
they showed the punch within it I assume
they showed the TMZ version unless they
had the HD version but I'm not sure Dre
mom would agree and lit the HD version
of that game show but I want to know you
know if I'm TMZ and I'm gonna buy that
video whoever leaked it why wouldn't I
show it all the way through the punch
and then what happened right after that
to me is just as interesting did
Draymond go to help him up was pool
knocked out did Steph Curry or Klay
Thompson or Steve Kerr do anything say
anything practice is closed so I I have
more questions attached to it I think if
Draymond goes over and helps him up and
you know I'm sorry then maybe it softens
it a little bit here but I'm curious why
cut off the video that you paid for
right after the punch yeah maybe that's
all they were sent but I I mean I could
tell you what I've heard no I mean he
had to be like pulled off and um as far
as Draymond went in for the kill like he
was I don't know that he was like uh
again like again this is secondhand
reporting I haven't seen the video on it
but I I don't think he was like throwing
more punches but I think he was it was
still like it was a situation where he
still needed maybe he was just talking
but had to be kind of separated and they
have a uh like an adjacent weight room
that like I think all of I've heard all
the veterans kind of dragged him over to
and like kind of had to calm him down uh
within that situation yeah
and through it all and and I agree with
you
um I loved him last year I love him
again this year I'm waiting to see that
youth movement we saw it with Jordan
Poole but you got kaminga and Moody you
got James Wiseman to make that next step
might be the key if this team's going to
win another championship with this group
um and then trying to get everybody
minutes as well is is going to be
challenged they're they're probably 10
Deep Anthony 11 11. you know Moody was
the 11th guy they put in last night in
the first half which is like you don't
do that in NBA rotations typically it's
like nine like stretch it to ten
um you know part of that is like Clay's
on a minute's limit
um but you know I mean I think Moses
Moody's ready like if you put Moses
Moody on the Charlotte Hornets I think
he's getting 30 minutes a night and he's
like got six minutes last night as the
11th man so uh I I like what I've seen
from the youth uh you know comparatively
to what last I saw them last I saw them
James Wiseman was not ready he looked
more ready last night I mean I thought
he was a very capable backup big man
um I liked what kamega did in the
preseason they're going to use them in
like switchable more athletic lineups
and this is a team historically that
really isn't that athletic it's more of
like a skill based team
um so so they're kind of like you know
infusing something new to this team you
saw more pick and roll with Wiseman on
the floor last night typically a very
anti-pick and roll team but him and pool
kind of have a nice mix there so it's
it's different and as somebody who has
to cover it on a daily basis I just like
watching like different versions of the
same team
all right give me your assessment of the
Lakers uh if I'm a Laker fan and I'm
listening to your opinion of what they
can expect this season what would that
be
they of the playoff hopefuls I think
they might have the worst like 3 through
15 3 through 10 roster in the league and
that's just a problem I mean they I
think you just saw last night like the
depth on display like what rotation lake
or Beyond LeBron and Anthony Davis would
be in the Warriors rotation I mean for
example Juan Tuscano Anderson who was
very you know useful for the Warriors
and and they love him there but last
year he did he was not in their playoff
rotation like he just sat on the bench
and watched the playoffs he would he
might be like their fifth or sixth best
player the Lakers currently
um it's just they're not deep they they
don't shoot they're really small in the
back court it's like a non-2022 type
team I do like like Davis looks good he
looked good in the preseason he had a 22
Point first half against the Warriors
when Draymond was away from the team
um and I you know I think that you know
gives them a nice one-two punch although
LeBron's 38 I I don't quite think he has
that Top Gear that he used to I think
you saw it last night Steph Curry closed
the door LeBron I'm not sure that gear
is there again when he's you know on in
those Titanic clashes against the
giannises of the world
um and if one two aren't completely
dominant and I just think they're you
know what you'd expect three through
fifteen like I I don't I see playing
uh definitely like I think I think it's
a seven through ten type team that might
even slip Beyond
uh Clippers still it feels like
everybody loves the Clippers out list
but what am I missing there with the
Clippers I know they got depth and you
got Kawhi and Paul George but then that
can also be part of the problem with
Kauai and Paul George
yeah I mean because we and we do this
and we do this in every sport before the
season like you just like health is like
guaranteed in your mind right every
single player is playing all 82 games
and like we'll be there in the playoffs
and if that is the case with the
Clippers if like their entire team is
available and Kawhi Leonard looks like
he did pre- ACL injury and we have no
idea I mean we've never we have not seen
Kawaii play but if that is the case yeah
they're theoretically built really well
deep uh their owner spends like crazy
just like the Warriors does they have
the two top tax bills ever
um and that is how you get more depth
right you're willing to pay basically
the Clippers get an extra Norm Powell
just like the Warriors getting extra
Andrew Wiggins
um to just beef up your roster and uh
you know and I think about them in a
West finals match if they are healthy uh
and they do you know profile as a team
that would defend the Warriors well a
bunch of wings switchable guys uh guys
with playoff history against the
Warriors Kawhi in particular may have
played better than anyone historically
against the Warriors in the playoffs so
I like them as a theoretical team but I
you know who will be available when will
they be available uh I have no idea
Anthony good to talk to you thanks for
joining us we appreciate it yep thanks
for having me Anthony Slater he covers
the Warriors and the NBA for the
athletic yeah every time I leave out the
Clippers when people say oh who do you
like out west and I somehow leave out
the Clippers I it's just having but uh
the odds are there for the Clippers to
be it looks like
that their odds might be better than
golden states right now to win it all
which I still find remarkable
uh feels like the Bucks became a sleeper
all of a sudden where you're like you
know everybody talks about the Nets you
know the Celtics have had drama James
Harden and the Sixers and Joel embiid
and then all of a sudden you go what
about the Bucks and the Bucks may like
it like that yeah morph they might end
up being like the Warriors you know the
Warriors are out of sight out of mind
because of injuries and things like that
and they might come back with a
vengeance and I think Giannis he might
be coming for an MVP only because people
are not writing them off but they're not
on the tip of everyone's tongues as far
as a playoff favorite
I wonder if Giannis can win another one
now
because what would he do where you'd go
yep
I mean It's Tricky when it comes to
voting and I voted on these Awards in
the NBA and and I wasn't fair looking
back on Barclays season and Carl
Malone's season when they won MVPs
because I still looked at the totality
of this season
and thought there's nobody more valuable
than Michael Jordan
and and it played out that way because
he beat the sons in the in the title for
the title that year and he beat Utah for
the title that year
foreign
looking back I I should have
acknowledged what Barclay had done and
Carl Malone had done I just thought okay
who's the most valuable player
and it's Michael Jordan
and I couldn't get that out of my mind
and that's how I voted yeah morph a guy
like Giannis the Bucks would have to
have an historic season they got to win
68-69 games and be completely dominant
in order for Giannis to win I think
you're right there because now Luca and
whoever else they're coming for it well
Luca is his window is is there it's just
at what point do you then move on
because there's going to be somebody
else then there's going to be a John
Moran it's almost like you know a
shooting gallery where you get to move
along and then nobody picked me off okay
I get to come back around and then all
of a sudden you have to have a good
story that's attached to this
uh NBA tip-off hotline presented by
DraftKings Sportsbook and official
sports betting partner of the NBA the
promo code is Patrick make any five
dollar bet this week get 200 if your
team wins